hey my name is abby jacobson and i play
carson shaw hi i'm chante adams and i
play max chapman hello my name is
roberta kalindras i play lupe garcia hi
i'm priscilla delgado and i play este
yay
i'm darcy cardon and i play greta gill
and we're here with buzzfeed to play a
game of who's who who's who
[Music]
okay
human to like i don't know exist she's a
tough one to be i don't want to do
anything i'm like
she's the hardest person for me to be in
a scene with yeah the laughing is a joke
yeah
roberta
what are you talking about do abby you
do no dude i can't it's really constant
and amazing and it's not just abby you
can really do everybody you're an
impression well if i had to do somebody
else i could step in
and you can also do well you can do
everybody yeah i don't want to call
people out too hard because some of them
are really good darcy yeah maybe darcy
yeah
i don't know if anyone really does that
but right she probably would darcy would
yeah
oh
i do an abby too yeah yeah so crazy
i i thought you said
maybe kelly a little bit callie make
kind of yeah kelly has some kelly yeah
she's like feral but
she has dirty fingernails but you know
what molly molly molly molly
kelly i was gonna go with molly
molly yeah yeah molly molly is kinda
yeah molly is maybelline yeah molly is
mabo yeah that's right that's right
yeah
my first instinct was melody yeah yeah
melanie field it's probably me i think
maybe you but like you do share but yeah
like we just dress very differently yeah
there are some similarities oh and bemi
is not at all yeah yeah that's true
everyone is kind of has like some
similarities and then like big
differences but
yeah i think like visually you
visually yeah i mean
[Music]
abby knows it like
abby
i don't know like
wait i did watch it a couple of times
darcy oh
yeah i think darcy might know the movie
better than me
but maybe i definitely know what's
missing
historically oh yeah
what
did
you what
caperland yeah because we know that for
a fact because we know that for a fact
you don't know that
yeah what did you take i didn't take
anything
no no
no
no
[Music]
melanie just that's my first dance yeah
melanie's very wise melanie's like
therapist vibes yeah maybe mel i was
about to say male yeah melanie she talks
about her partner yeah and love the most
yeah so i think that's why like we would
go to her yeah yeah
[Music]
kelly roberta darcy yeah that that trio
probably yeah
honestly probably abby yeah or you
you think yeah you'd just be like okay i
know it would be that it would be that
[Music]
me
i feel like the other day you were
pulling out some i did i did the other
day yeah but malioson really yeah
but you were like really like
me
yeah i'm good at it yeah you're good i'm
good at it molly molly
you think melanie loves stick yeah
oh yeah she's a tick tucker that's right
i mean she knows the wrap dance oh
that's oh yeah
now from the top you know yeah that that
dance and then the lizzo the new yeah
yeah she really does that's true yeah
she's probably tick-tocking right right
now yeah this second
[Music]
bemi
you know she also lives on the other
side of the world so
she's on the other side of the world too
true some of the time but i we always
think it might be time zone right or
different carrier yeah
kelly yeah kelly just would like
disappear to like a
like a deserted island yeah she'd be
like i was like in
antarctica yeah i was learning how to
fish and i came
for a month and now i'm back what did i
miss
okay or you're because your number's
always changing yeah oh yeah that's true
or betty because she's on like
nine hours ahead of us yeah and she'll
be like what did i do
is your name fred
uh you you you yeah you definitely and
you're putting the little filter on
there i don't know i don't know maybe
darce
yeah i know or priscilla priscilla okay
yeah
i think priscilla is young and is like
yeah
youngest gal yeah yeah
um probably yeah me you yeah i'm always
we're always yeah like
me
i am one of them yeah
it's i i've gone to craft services with
you you're like good at it oh she's like
knows when to go and you're like you're
getting stuff for like the day
yes and for the night i know she's like
i do not buy snacks when i i know it's
really i was i think the first time i
went with you i was like oh
thanks so much buzzfeed thank you guys
thank you so much
you and remember to watch a league of
their own on amazon prime
let's play ball yeah
[Music]
me